على عتاب المستويات المطلوبه لصناعه سلاح
نووي تقف طهران حسب اخر تقرير للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بنسبه نقاء بلغت
ثلاثه
وسبعه عشر في المئه وقريبه من نسبه 90%
التي تحتاجها الدول لصناعه قنبله نوويه
تقول الوكاله انها وجدت عينات يورانيوم في
منشاه فوردو قفزه كبيره في معدلات التخصيب
بلغتها ايران يشير التقرير بعد ان انفلت
الطهران من اغلال الاتفاق النووي الذي كان
يقيد عمل المفاعلات النوويه ويحد نسبه
التخصيب المسموح بها في ثلاثه وسته اعشار
في المئه تحت اليات صارمه للمراقبه بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي بشكل احادي في عهد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب رفع
الطهران بشكل تدريجي نسبه التخصيب الى نحو
60% لكن التقرير الاخير اشار الى ان ازاله
طهران معدات اصابتها الوكاله للكشف
والمراقبه حد من قدرتها على للوصول الى
تفاصيل عمليات التخصيب في المفاعلات
النوويه كما وكيفا وهو ما يبقي مجال
التكهن بخصوص كميات اليورانيوم التي
خصبتها ايران حتى الان علما ان انتاج سلاح
نووي يتطلب على الاقل 25 كيلو جراما بدرجه
نقاء تتراوح ما بين 90 وخمسه وتسعين في
المئه تنفي طهران هذه الاتهامات وترد بان
معطيات التقرير قديمه وان نقاط الخلاف فيه
تم تسويتها على مستوى الخبراء الذين زاروا
ايران خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين نفي اخر
جاء على لسان رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد اسلامي الذي اكد ان ما تم
كشفه ذرات معدودات لا يمكن ان ترى بالعين
المجرده لكن هذه التطمينات لا تبدد هواجس
الغرب والغرب هنا ليس جبهه موحده فيما
يبدو فباريس وصفت الامر بالخطير وغير
المسبوق وفي الوقت الذي تتحفز فيه فرنسا
والمانيا وبريطانيا
قرار في اعقاب اجتماع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه الاسبوع المقبل يوجه اللوم
رسميا لطهران لاقترابها من بلوغ العتبه
النوويه تبدو اداره الرئيس بايدن متردده
في سلوك هذا الدرب صحيفه الويسر جورنال
التي نقلت الخبر استبعدت ان تنجح مساعي
الدول الاوروبيه في صياغه البيان دون دعم
الولايات المتحده ولعل واشنطن تنتظر نتائج
زياره مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الى طهران حيث يتوقع ان يطالب رافاييل
غروسي الرئيس الايراني بالتقديم توضيحات
بشان العينات التي وجدها المفتشون
الدوليون في منشاه فورد النوويه قبيل
اجتماع مجلس محافظ الوكاله المقرر في
فيينا الاثنين المقبل